my name is Sam Hargrave I was the second
unit director and stunt coordinator on
atomic blonde today we're gonna do a
stunt breakdown in the father figure
sequence from the film is we call a
picture hit the elbow is kind of the
center point so you don't extend your
arm past your elbow as you can see she
extends her elbow first he is back at a
safe distance it looks like he's right
on top of her but he's back about you
know eight to 12 inches there
so she extends her elbow out and then
extends the hose out and it looks like
it hits him right on the nose and he
does a great reaction the Hat flies off
and those little details you know we try
to you know find and execute we're put
the Hat on loosely because we know it's
it's kind of like hair in at long hairs
a better better than the egg a bald head
Charlie is thrown trained a lot for this
sequence we had her in LA for probably
six or eight weeks before principal
photography and the stuff I love about
movies is you know these guys had to do
this over and over again and underneath
this carpet you know we had some stunt
pads that way you can really get
Charlize doing it it's less risk of her
getting injured and she did this this is
her we just trained to her in a lot of
judo so she's throwing a little judo in
the mix they're a little tight oh she
tossing head over heels in an instance
like this the actor and stunt performer
worked together you know a real fight
throwing somebody's not easy
they were together she's really
motivating him but he's helping her he
gets light and when she does the move he
goes with her and tumbles over and makes
it look dramatic and painful
the magic of movies in the beauty of
visual effects nowadays working well
with stunts this floor was padded and so
where he was falling we had a one-inch
foam mat screen printed to look like the
floor so he could do this repeatedly and
there's a bit of like little detail of a
gun disarmed with the hose trying to
think of different ways to utilize it as
a defensive weapon got a table with some
glass on it you got to break it this one
is real glass and we put underneath that
carpet again had a nice stunt mat so the
guy could do it repeatedly and not get
too banged up we had special effects you
can kind of see once he breaks the table
the glass explodes very dramatically so
we had special effects have a glass
poppers all neat corners there as soon
as soon as he hits it but when they give
it a nice dramatic effect because a lot
of times a glass breaking is kind of
boring like it breaks and falls straight
down
so just for a better effect in the
movies they've special effects get in
there with their explosive devices and
make it a little more exciting for
camera we come back to this guy so here
we tried to mess this environment like
what would be there what could you use
these guys are armed how can you combat
their weapons with everyday
environmental weapons and you can see
here I didn't notice this before but
it's a fun little detail or rubber pot
watch the handle and she grabs it
boi-oi-oi-oi-oing yelling there are many
instances where you use an editing
technique cut frame dropping where you
want to speed up certain aspects of the
of a fight or make something have a
little more impact this is one of them
to make up this location look even more
powerful so it goes from here to that
moment so you drop a frame when it it's
kind of shockingly fast another place
the editors did that is right here
there's a few frames skipped to speed
this moment up so you go from this first
side of the disarm to the guns gone you
know again with a sound effect at speed
it makes it seem extremely fast and
violent here
you got like it's just had added a
little trick that editors like to use
and it's it's effective it was like
great great reaction from our stunt guy
here and she's really just going for it
and a lot of times it's up to this stunt
performer to sell the power of the hit
from the actor but also here Charlize
does a great job of selling the hit and
she's twisting into Italy like she wraps
all the way around the other side of her
body punk and this we did in to this is
like a stitch you can see the frames
kind of repeat so if she did her first
shot and then we camera whipped off into
nothing and then for the next piece we
had the guys stand there and we actually
this is a rubber pan rubber pie whether
you call this and we hate him in the
face of it we have and he did I think
that was 13 times and you can kind of
see the hand there if you see that on
the edge of for the right edge of frame
there it's not supposed to be there but
you can see the guy the hand in real
life like for a woman with fighting
you're up against men what do you do to
overcome these adversaries so for lack
of a better like cliche is a nut shots
are great
he's wearing a groin protector a cup and
just got this is our stunt double doing
it and she's quite accurate with her her
kicks and the performer getting kicked
you can kind of roll your pelvis forward
and kind of raise the dangerous bits and
you kind of live with the toe of the
person kicking we kind of reach a little
bit and go more for the the padded area
of the rump so you can make more contact
and it actually at speed you know it
looks extremely painful it's probably a
big reaction from all the men in the
audience and then she turns and gives
she's on a roll with the groin shots
goes the HOS little whip it right to the
groin there and so here we smash the guy
with the fridge and you can again these
little details of moviemaking you can
see on the refrigerator door you see the
the outline here is not perfect this is
a foam piece that we cut and painted to
go on top
the fridge and you can see as we go to
the side how it sticks out a little bit
more on the fridge
and so we you know smashed our stunt guy
in the face with a door of the fridge
and he's preparing back there with the
mouthpiece and he knows it's coming you
know attack you can see him right there
he's attacking it watching him lean his
head into it
ah boom which is often better than
rather than waiting to get hit just kind
of go at it it's better in my opinion to
go big once and get it rather than you
know timidly doing the door cuz the guy
gets it anyway it's more accumulation
that you get injured or hurt by like
instead of just getting hit one time
hard with the door and I've got it
moving on
you hit him up little harder please and
now it's ten times and the guy's got a
concussion and you're like just hit him
once the first time hard and so we did
this was I think one time maybe twice
for this but she just Wham
this shows off a lot of her training
because and it's fun to do that with so
you don't have to hide an actor's
inadequacies with cuts or shaky cam like
this camera it just sits here and it's
on it you know just adjust the framing
but just watches her go through all
these moves and beat up the Sun guys and
they had she'd rehearsed this for a
number of days and you bring in bringing
the guys on the day and they rehearse it
for Cameron even on the day we'd you
know we'd be doing it means like how
it's just not working so these this
would change I get every one of these
straight like this guy was here and then
we this ended up it was like probably an
hour of just what's working best what's
flowing best and it you know we ended up
with this which is why her training of
being you know in the gym and learning a
lot of different moves that go together
not just those specific rote routines it
allows her to be flexible and it gives
us the the dynamic range of action that
we kind of sometimes neat yeah you can
see there it's happening so fast that he
sells it real great but he's not getting
hit in the face it's probably a good six
to eight inches short
but at speed that sound effects and
whatnot just it sounds like hitting them
saying with this one she went you know
behind his head so he's there and she
went off behind and she did a good job
of dragging we call it so instead of
pointing your wrist and the whole thing
stick out on the head she dragged it
through so she was less likely to
overextend and crack our guy on top of
the head we had again the use of special
effects and their explosive charges to
blow the table on this one is two
separate takes we shot two cameras
simultaneously we had one here that
would follow into the ground and one
receiving him which was the angle that
they ended up using for the second half
this part but you can see them as
different takes cos on this one he's
flying almost over the table you see it
break right below his legs they're on
the bottom of frame here you can see it
start to break and he goes over it like
he's poof he's on a cable here so we had
a cable attached to his back he's
wearing a vest
got a jerk vest covers his upper torso
a very low-profile lightweight but very
strong material and they had a cable
attached to his back which they later
digitally eliminate see this this dust
kind of flying up here as and you can
see it go up see that in the
glass-breaking here that's where the
special effects
have their little explosive charge so as
soon as he touches it leg press their
button and the charge goes up which
breaks the glass otherwise and we had
one happen where the charge did not go
off and the whole sheet of glass went
with him people that make glass there
they know that it's fragile so they make
it not to break so things are not easy
to break and usually with that kind of
glass with tempered glass it's it's not
a question of if you're gonna get cut
it's a where and how bad
this is on a stage so we built built
this and the stage is elevated about 10
feet off the ground and that's not easy
like that's not an easy thing to do to
get your your steps in line that railing
like which is narrow it's only about 2
inches wide with as you know boots on
she is not on a cable for this that she
just free jumped it she jumped right
down and then the the double she is on a
cable and a wire rig above for this
camera is and so it slows her down
enough that when redirects her inside on
this next piece here you can see when
she hits the end of this Thursday Oh for
jarring and it even the camera guy
wasn't quite ready for that and they did
that all you know all in one that was to
be had three cameras and in this one
they just painted out the cameras on top
that would be like when we had a rig
here that came out and that with the
cable was attached to and they had a
camera up in here they just digitally
replaced it all and so this one we had
some pads down there on the bottom and
we we set this up this is a real desk
he's going over and like all right
whatever you do don't land on your head
yeah he did but we loved it so much then
we asked him to do it again and you can
kind of actually see right if you look
down here you can kind of see see the
outline of this stunt pad down here and
then here we hooked him again to a cable
and pulled out the Lissette wall on the
side so that we could get our dolly
track and that glass that you see there
that's all silicon glass and then you
see the oh that hard impact the yanked
him and he had a back protector on there
and we just gave him a good old yank
right into that steel fence actually one
of the harder bits was this one just
because of the the nature of it and she
had a platform out probably 15 or 20
feet back from that that railing and
then maybe yes like 15 feet high she was
just holding on to the
near the hose and she swung in let go
and hit the door just and then right to
the ground
I mean she's super slick but not you
know she didn't land like in a
three-point pose like Iron Man or Spider
Man it's like yeah that stuff's not easy
to do so we tried to make as fun as that
fight is and as unrealistic as a lot of
that stuff is we tried to add enough
realism to where you feel like she's
human it's a great way to end that
sequence